and now by the way i'm not joking i'm
not being hyperbolic california students
are being told to chant prayers to those
gods
on august 26th the thomas more society
wrote a letter to the state
superintendent of public instruction
requesting that they remove an aztec
prayer
from the state's curriculum
now
the state refused to respond to this so
now the thomas more society has filed a
lawsuit california in in march of this
year
introduced a new ethnic studies
curriculum ethnic studies is a fake
academic discipline for students who are
too stupid to study real academic
disciplines so it it
but it's not just because some students
are not intelligent or educated enough
to take real courses it's also because
the left is trying to impose its own
radical ideology on a whole generation
of students and they're doing that in
the classrooms not just at the
universities but also in
high school and middle school and you
know even further back so they
introduced this new ethnic studies uh
requirement
and it was promoted by a man who
believes that one way to rectify
colonialism is to support a
counter-genocide of quote white
christians not a joke
he
he calls on students quote
to challenge racist bigoted
discriminatory imperialist colonial
beliefs and practices on multiple levels
and one way they're doing that
is having students chant prayers to the
aztec gods
tetscott lapoca and witsel lapachtli i'm
you know not pronouncing this correctly
i would assume
this latter god is the god of war among
others and a god
to whom the aztecs would sacrifice many
many people by
stabbing them in the chest and ripping
out their hearts while they were still
beating and now our students are
chanting prayers to them why why what
the left is going to say is oh michael
stop getting so hung up on this it's not
a real religious ritual
it's not like a real liturgy
it's j it's just a fun thing to explore
other cultures it's just a fun thing to
chant prayers to demon gods sometimes
but it's not you're not really praying
to the demon gods
but you you are
you are though you are literally doing
that
i was in new york over the weekend what
do you think i had two hours free first
thing i do i go to the cigar club i have
a nice drink i have a cigar the place i
get my cigars
thompson i've been a customer there
since i was 16 since my mother gave me
my first box of cigars christmas when i
was 16 i still have some of them from
thompson you can get one of those cigars
the oliva series o little perfecto cigar
in the knoll sampler pack you get a ton
of other stuff too man of war armada
davidoff cigar ep carrillo el cenadore
nat sherman timeless nat sherman another
great new york tobacco company
this sampler should be
double or triple at probably more like
triple the price of what it actually is
right now they've just got an amazing
deal on it people always ask me michael
what should i smoke i don't know about
cigarettes get the null sampler pack the
way you get the null sampler pack is you
go to
thompsoncigar.com slash knowles canada
wles they're lit they're offering our
listeners 15 off orders over 75 bucks
for 20 off orders over 99 bucks to take
advantage of these truly incredible
savings thompsoncigar.com knowles use
promo code knowles when you're ready to
check out t-h-o-m-p-s-o-n-cigar.com
knowles use promo code knowles you will
thank me later
when you perform rituals
it with your bodies with your speech
with it when you when you do that
that
is a religious right
it is and and you might not realize it
you might think you're being really
clever just like the huffington post
thinks they're being devilishly clever
it looks like we're partnering up with
satanists to preserve the sacrament the
antichrist sacrament of abortion but
we're not really doing that we're just
we're just
you know
science promoters
we're just secularists we're just it's
not really satanic
we're just sort of ironically satanic
if you
if you perform an activity or a ritual
or a right
ironically
forever and ever and ever you just keep
doing it it's no longer ironic
when you pray
to demon gods but it's ir ironically but
you you just you do it you actually are
doing it with you
you've actually done it you're actually
doing something this is probably not a
good idea so the the thomas more society
what they're trying to do is say keep
religion out of the schools we can't
have this prayer to the aztec demon gods
human sacrifice because you know that
that would be imposing religion on
schools and we're not allowed to do that
so let's stop that
whatever we got to do to get the demon
god prayers out of schools i guess
that's a good place to start but i don't
think this line of attack of keep
religion out of schools i don't think
it's ultimately going to be successful
i think
we need to grapple with the much more
difficult question
but ultimately more correct one which is
acknowledging that we will have a
religion in schools all education is
oriented toward certain goals certain
ideals of ethics and morality and yes
religion metaphysics a recognition of
how the human person relates to the
world and we've got to make some choices
what kind of education are they going to
get
what kind of moral order are they
looking at
what do they believe about the human
person
that's going to require certain
religious premises
and ultimately ultimately they need to
be christian
okay because our civilization is a
christian civilization and if we have
if we have our education ordered toward
some different thing then it's going to
be a different civilization and it's
going to be a worse one and our kids are
going to worship demon gods
[Music]
you